من حلبة المصارعة
إلى الحلبة السياسية .
.وفي المعارك تجده في مقدمة الصفوف ..
هو رجل ديني هادئ ملتزم
ولكن الرقص هوايته،
الجندي الشرس لروسيا
وفتى بوتين المدلل،
الذي قال عنه بوتين يوما أنه الولد الذي لم أنجبه،
رئيس دولة برتبة مصارع، وعسكري برتبة لواء،
هو شيخ صوفي ملتحي يفدي بوتين بحياته،
هو الرئيس الوحيد الذي يدخل على بوتين
بدون استئذان، شاب مسلم شيشاني
قوي البنية مفتول العضلات ذو لحية شقراء،
ذكي ماكر، انتهج أقصر الطرق ليصبح
رئيس الشيشان الأول وهو شاب صغير،
هو الرئيس الأوحد في العالم
الذي يعاقب مسؤوليه الفاسدين بجولة
في حلبة المصارعة..
(عن رمضان قديروف نتحدث وللقصة بقية)
رمضان أحمدوفِيتْش قَدِيروف،
أو  كما يقال (بالعربية: رمضان بن أحمد آل قدير)
، هو ابن الرئيس الشيشاني السابق أحمد قديروف.
ولد قديروف في ٥أكتوبر ١٩٧٦،
..كان لرمضان أخ أكبر منه اسمه زيليمخان
(لكنه توفي عام 2004) ،
في المدرسة كان شخصاً متهوراً.
وكان قديروف دائماً يسعى للحصول
على تقدير والده الإمام أحمد قديروف
وكان دائماً يحاول تقليد والده.
كان شغوفاً بالملاكمة حتى أنه التقى بالملاكم
العالمي من الوزن الثقيل مايك تايسون..
قاتل رمضان قديروف إلى جانب والده
ضد القوات المسلحة الروسية، وبعد الحرب
رمضان أصبح السائق والحارس الشخصي لوالده
أحمد قديروف..
ويعد رمضان من أتباع التيار الصوفي،
كما يدعم تعدد الزوجات.
وهو مشهور بامتلاكه للسيارات الرياضية الفارهة
والخناجر الشيشانية ومشاركته في سباقات للخيول
وهوايته في ممارسة الملاكمة.
قديروف كان قد حصل على رتبة لواء
في الحرس الوطني الروسي عام 2000
(قديروف القائد)
في عام ٢٠٠٤ تم اغتيال رئيس الشيشان
ووالد رمضان، أحمد قديروف،
وهناك بدأت قيادة رمضان:
ففي 2005 تم احتجاز اخته من قبل الشرطة
الداغستانية فقام رمضان قديروف
ومعه حوالي 150 رجل مسلح بالتوجه إلى
مركز شرطة مدينة خاسافيورت واجبروا
رجال الشرطة على الرضوخ لهم تحت تهديد السلاح
واخرجوا زولاي قاديروف من السجن..
وفي العام ذاته خرج رمضان قديروف ليصرح،
بأنه سيبني أكبر مسجد في أوروبا،
وقل أن الشيشان هي المكان الأكثر مسالمة في روسيا"
وفي غضون بضع سنوات ستصبح
"أثرى وأغنى الأماكن في العالم".
ليعلن بذلك أن الحرب قد انتهت بالفعل
وأن ما تبقى لا يتجاوز 150 "لصاً" كما وصفهم
(يقصد المعارضين)
وقال قديروف أنه انتقم من الذي قتل والده
وسيقتل الذين وقفوا خلفه واحدا واحدا
حتى وإن يقتل أو يسجن هو بنفسه
وفي عام ٢٠٠٧ وافق البرلمان الشيشاني
على تعيين رمضان قديروف رئيسا للبلاد
بمباركة فلاديمير بوتين، وما هي إلا أيام
حتى بدأ التغيير في السلطات الشيشانية
ليحكم رمضان قبضته على البلاد بأسرها،،
وفي عام ٢٠٠٩ قال قديرف:
كل الأمراء والأشخاص الذين كانوا أفراداً سابقين
في تشكيلات مسلحة غير شرعية،
والذين هم الآن في أوروبا، والذين لم تتلطخ أيديهم
بالدماء لديهم خياران:
إما أن يعودوا ويعملوا لصالح وطنهم،
أو يبقوا هناك لبقية حياتهم...
(نهضة اقتصادية )
في عام 2010 رئيس الوفد البريطاني
لجماعة حقوق الإنسان لورد جود والذي كان
قد صرح سابقاً أنه "يشعر بالحرج بشكل مرير
من السلطات الروسية بسبب الوضع في الشيشان"،
أشار إلى أن هناك تغير واضح نحو الأفضل
في الجمهوريات الشمال قوقازية.
جود قال أن التغييرات التي حصلت منذ اخر زيارة
للمفوضية في 2000 كانت كبيرة للغاية
للدرجة التي ينسى فيها الشخص ما قد حصل
هنا في وقت ليس ببعيد
(قديروف و الكرملين وفلاديمير بوتين)
رمضان قديروف هو الرئيس الأقرب إلى الزعيم الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ويعتبر واحداً من أكثر الشخصيات
قرباً إلى الكرملين. وقد أعلن قديروف عدة مرات
وفي عدة مناسبات أنه يهب حياته دفاعاً عن روسيا
وعن الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين وكتب ذلك
على صفحته على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك،،
كما صرح قائلاً "
إن رئيس الشيشان وجنود الشيشان جميعهم
مستعدون للتضحية من أجل الرئيس بوتين
من أجل الدفاع عن روسيا"،،
وأكد أنه مستعد للموت من أجل روسيا والرئيس بوتين.
وبسبب قوة العلاقة بين فلاديمير بوتين ورمضان قديروف
فقد أُطلق على قديروف لقب فتى بوتين المدلل
(موقفه من غزو أوكرانيا)
قبل بدأ الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا قال قديروف
أن من حق روسيا أن تحافظ على أمنها،
وبعدما بدأت الحرب جهز جيشا مكونا
من ١٠آلاف مقاتل شيشاني(بحسب بعض التقارير)
وضمهم إلى قوات موسكو على الأرض الأوكرانية،
وقال رمضان: إن مقاتلي القوات الخاصة الشيشانية
يتقدمون بثقة في عمق أوكرانيا،
ويحررون خلال ذلك المراكز السكنية من القوميين المتعصبين.
(قديروف كان قد قال أن بوتين اتخذ القرار الصائب
وسننفذ أوامره مهما كانت الظروف)
وهو يقصد بذلك غزو أوكرانيا..
وأضاف إنه يمكنه حشد 70 ألف متطوع
للقتال في أوكرانيا.
وطلب قديروف من بوتين عدم الالتفات
إلى ما يحدث "والسماح لنا بإنهاء كل شيء"
كما أردف:
(إنني رجل متواضع، وأنني مستعد للتضحية
بحياتي من أجلك. لكن لا يمكنني مشاهدة
مقاتلينا الذين يموتون".
كل هذه المفاوضات لا طائل من ورائها،
فكلما طال انتظارنا زادت العقوبات التي تنتج عنها".)
(من طرائف قديروف)
استدعى رمضان أحد وزرائه إلى حلبة ملاكمة
لمعاقبته على أخطائه عارضاً عبر الإنترنت
صورا للواقعة التي صورها التلفزيون الروسي،
وجاء النزال بعدما أعرب الزعيم الشيشاني
عن عدم رضاه بسبب تقدم عملية ترميم
مبنى وزارة الرياضة المتهالك في جمهورية الشيشان،
حيث قرر قديروف الذي يجيد فنون القتال
والدفاع عن النفس، معاقبة وزير الرياضة
سلام بيك إسماعيلوف بخوض مباراة ملاكمة معه.
وقال قديروف خلال حوارنا أو جدالنا شرحت له
بلطف بقبضة يدي اليمني واليسرى أن عليك
أن تعمل برأسك، ولأن الوزير بدأ يصحح أخطاءه،
سمحت له بارتداء خوذة".
كغيره من القادة الكبار يخضع قديروف
لعقوبات أمريكية مغلظة وهو ممنوع من السفر
إلى أمريكا أيضا، لكن ذلك لم يمنعه من تطوير بلاده
بل أنه صار بطلا يشار له بالبنان في الشرق الأوسط
ويتم استقباله في الدول العربية،
وقبل كأس العالم ٢٠١٨ في روسيا
استقبل قديروف اللاعب المصري محمد صلاح،
الملقب بفخر العرب وقام بجولة معه في أرضية الملعب...
فهل يكتفي قديروف بإنجازاته في بلاده
أم يتجه للمشاركة في قضايا خارجية وإسلامية
على وجه الخصوص؟